[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
France 24 nuestra invitada hoy es Bianca
jagger fundadora y presidenta de la
fundación de Derechos Humanos Bianca
jagger bienvenido Muchísimas gracias por
invitarme vamos a hablar de El doctorado
honoris causa que otorgó la universidad
de sorbon Nobel a Dora María Téllez una
sandinista histórica que está detenida
hace desde hace junio de 2021 juzgada
culpable de Conspiración para menoscabar
la integridad Nacional de Nicaragua
este precio que significa
Creo que este reconocimiento no
solamente es por sus méritos Pero creo
que es un reconocimiento simbólico que
la sorbona le ofrece a Dora María Téllez
que es una prisionera que está siendo
torturada que está en estado de
aislamiento que ha hecho una huelga de
hambre para que le permitan por lo menos
recibir visitas verdad y y creo que es
muy importante porque el dárselo a ella
no solamente es adora María Téllez que
se lo dan pero se lo dan a los 225
prisioneros políticos que en Nicaragua
hoy día inocentes que Nicaragua hoy día
está siendo torturados y muchos de Ellos
están en estado de aislamiento a los que
no se les permite la visita de su
familiares y yo he escrito una carta
donde yo enumero todas las y los malos
tratos y las tortura a los que lo
someten pero no solamente a ellos porque
le someten ahora a sus familiares cuando
sus familiares vienen a recibirlo los
hacen desnudarse inclusive a señoras de
mucha edad desnudarse a ser cluquillas
no sé si se llame en español verdad
mientras ellos se ríen se burlan y es
una una humillación una falta de respeto
una una forma de tortura
lo que es interesante y triste también
es que bueno como dije ella era una
sandinista histórica que ayudó a Daniel
Ortega al final de los setentas y
también aprendimos hace unos días la
detención del sociólogo Oscar René
Vargas que era uno de los fundadores del
frente sandinista de liberación nacional
qué está pasando ahora y sabe que
Óscar que está hablando René le salvó la
vida a Daniel Ortega Pero entonces usted
tiene esa figura icónicas esa figuras de
la Revolución sandinista como Dora María
Téllez que está en la cárcel o como
comandante uno el general Julio Torres
que también participó en esa en la toma
de Posesión del Palacio Nacional pero
que también participó en una otra toma
donde se liberó a Daniel Ortega quiero
decir que Daniel Ortega no respeta a
nadie que ya sean los candidatos
prepresidenciales que ya sean los
sacerdotes y los y los y los obispos que
están en la cárcel o secuestrado que ya
sean las mujeres que ya sean los
defensores de Derechos Humanos que sean
los los hombres de negocios los
campesinos los estudiantes que están en
la cárcel hoy día Nicaragua y cualquier
persona que tiene que Osa verdad querer
una Nicaragua libre y democrática va a
la cárcel tiene que huir o lo Asesinan
en Nicaragua está Daniel Ortega solo o
también Rosario Murillo Daniel Ortega y
Rosario Murillo Perdóneme que me haya
olvidado de mencionar eso porque ellos
down son una son figuras simbióticas son
figuras perversas son figuras criminales
y yo diría también dos figuras
desquiciadas porque eso es la conducta
de estos dos dictadores criminales que
han cometido crímenes de lesa humanidad
en Nicaragua Pero qué quieren una
Dinastía Ortega quieren una Dinastía o
sea creo ustedes como usted sabe yo
tengo una larga trayectoria como
defensora de los Derechos Humanos yo he
tenido que con dictadores en en
[Música]
la antigua en la antigua yugoslavia
dictadores en muchos países del mundo y
entonces llega un momento en el cual
ellos saben que necesitan el poder
necesitan estar el poder para no hacerle
frente a la justicia o a la justicia
internacional y eso es Creo yo que
Daniel Ortega A dónde podría ir si
si fuera si lo sacaran de su poder puede
ir a Irán podría ir a Rusia con los que
tiene muchas relaciones muy peligrosas
en Nicaragua podría ir tal vez a Cuba
pero a ellos parece que no les gusta
mucho la señora Murillo podría ir a
Venezuela y no sé dónde más tal vez
podría ir a México hay sanciones contra
Nicaragua contra el régimen Pero eso
basta o eso funciona o no las acciones
funcionan es necesario que la Unión
Europea es necesario también que los
Estados Unidos que Canadá que los países
latinoamericanos impongan sanciones
económicas más contundentes más
efectivas ellos han hecho eso han
arrastrado los pies si quiere un poco la
comunidad internacional en particular
diría yo la Unión Europea y los países
latinoamericanos pero creo que ya se
están dando cuenta que verdaderamente
verdaderamente es imperativo que esas
acciones se les imponga a Daniel Ortega
y no solo las sanciones hay como los
organismos como el el fondo monetario
internacional recientemente hizo un
reporte verdad escandaloso que
presenta Nicaragua como un país donde se
puede ir a invertir le han dado le han
seguido dando ayuda desde el banco
centroamericano el Banco Mundial también
deberían de saber que Nicaragua es una
dictadura donde se están cometiendo
crímenes de lesa humanidad y que no se
les debe de continuar dando a préstamos
a Nicaragua el gobierno Tal vez es para
ayudar la población de Nicaragua que
sufre mucho es yo como defensora de
Derechos Humanos por muchos años me
opuse a esas sanciones por eso
desgraciadamente cuando usted llega a un
punto en el cual usted tiene una
dictadura tan brutal como la que tenemos
en Nicaragua que entonces la única forma
porque aquí no hay una lucha armada en
Nicaragua quiere decir no tenemos una
Revolución ya murieron mucha gente en
Nicaragua y los nicaragüenses no quieren
otra Revolución no quieren una una
Revolución Armada Entonces cómo hacemos
para deshacernos de Daniel Ortega y del
Rosario Murillo imponerles sanciones
hacerlos que el poderío económico que
tenga haga que tal vez muchos de
aquellos que me apoyan no lo sigan
apoyando quiero hablar de otro actor
importante Nicaragua la Iglesia Católica
Hace unos días el arzobispo de Managua
el cardenal Leopoldo brenes expresó que
el diálogo con el gobierno Ortega nunca
debe de tenerse tras un encuentro con el
Papa Francisco
sabemos que Daniel Ortega acusa a la
iglesia católica desde la represión de
de no estar alguien neutral y que ayuda
a la oposición Qué quiere decir esta
posición del arzobismo Bueno yo
recientemente he puesto un video porque
yo he hecho una campaña en apoyo a la
iglesia católica en apoyo
particularmente a monseñor o al obispo
Rolando Álvarez un hombre extraordinario
que nos nicaragüenses que está
secuestrado está secuestrado con más de
112 días probablemente hoy verdad que no
sabemos Dónde está que hemos tenido
noticia que no está bien de salud
también hay secuestrado once
sacerdotes que están en la cárcel hoy
día con seminaristas y otras personas
que estaban con él hay una guerra
diría yo una guerra diabólica contra la
Iglesia Católica y no entiendo
verdaderamente porque el cardenal brenes
dice que puede haber un diálogo con el
gobierno o con el desgobierno de Rosario
Murillo y Daniel Ortega porque realmente
lo que está ocurriendo es una
persecución continua de los sacerdotes
que están escapándose O que están en la
cárcel o que están secuestrados y que no
les permiten regresar a Nicaragua
Entonces yo le hago un llamado al santo
padre que se lo he hecho en varias
ocasiones
mi padre porque usted no condena a el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega y Rosario
Murillo Por qué no menciona al obispo
Rolando Álvarez Y por qué no se preocupa
públicamente porque no lo dice que hay
que liberar a un Obispo en Nicaragua que
está secuestrado después de más de 100
días y el cual nosotros tenemos por su
vida por favor santo padre
recuérdese lo que ocurrió en El Salvador
no queremos otro mártir en Nicaragua
necesitamos que usted alce su voz y que
diga que condena al desgobierno de
Daniel Ortega y Rosario Murillo y que
usted se preocupa por la vida de
monseñor Rolando Álvarez y por los
sacerdotes en Nicaragua y por los presos
políticos que tenemos en el país Bianca
Muchísimas gracias Y muchísimas gracias
[Música]